[Musique]
le mag au cœur du Salon International de
l'Agriculture bonjour et bienvenue à
tous ce lundi Marc un temps fort du
salon l'inauguration du village réunion
le conseil départemental et ses
partenaires on salué la force de cette
édition 2023
un salon qui s'agrandit qui prend de
l'espace et s'installe au premier étage
du pavillon 5 et 800 m² avec un plus
grand nombre d'exposants et plus de
diversité dans les produits et
savoir-faire proposer la Réunion voix
grand et traduisez une volonté forte de
promouvoir la production locale
cette édition 2023 et certainement
l'une des plus belles peut-être même la
plus belle je parle des gens en termes
de fréquentation sur les premiers jours
le sang de réunion a eu un succès
phénoménal beaucoup fréquentations et
j'ai vu des exposants me dire que les
produits se vendent comme des petits
pains donc cela prouve bien qu'il y a
vraiment un beau et grand succès pour
aller produire de la Réunion et pour le
stand réunion en général toute
l'agriculture est fier de se montrer
mais même au-delà de nos frontières la
Réunion arrive à fédérer au niveau
métropolitain le salon de que tu as
internationale et la plus belle fête qui
existe sur le territoire métropolitain
et on est là du champ directement à
l'assiette ce salon crée un espace de
vente directe entre le producteur et le
consommateur il offre des opportunités
de marché il contribue également à la
promotion et à l'exportation de la
destination Réunion c'est une excellente
à valoriser on a des fruits qui sont
d'excellents on a notre ananas je dis à
chaque fois que c'est la Rolls Royce de
l'ananas c'est l'ananas Victoria 85% de
notre flux touristique vient de France
de l'Hexagone moins de 10% vient
d'Europe et donc établir une base ici
d'abondance une ambition partagée saluer
dans l'assemblée des regards des
sourires mais surtout que la
convivialité
[Musique]
au coeur du salon et même culture
partager ici les frontières sont tombées
la magie d'un moment
temps fort de la matinée la visite
attendue d'Elizabeth borne la première
ministre accompagnée du ministre de
l'Agriculture Marc féno accueilli par
une délégation des lieux la première
ministre a saluer la qualité des
savoir-faire et témoigner de son soutien
à la production locale le stand de la
Réunion est-ce que c'est l'occasion de
tisser des liens avec l'outre-mer en
général et la Réunion en particulier
alors c'est l'occasion de reconnaître
une partie de notre territoire qui a
beaucoup de spécificités qui est une
vraie richesse pour pour notre pays et
effectivement on voit toutes les
traditions on voit aussi toute la
démarche qui est en cours pour plus de
souveraineté alimentaire et ça c'est
vraiment quelque chose qu'on soutient
quand vous voyez tout ça est-ce que vous
vous dites que la réunion se donne les
moyens de ses ambitions alors oui j'ai
très envie de venir rapidement voir sur
place
pour souvenir de votre passage sur le
village réunion quelques souvenirs et
puis sans doute aussi
quelques
romsé des productions hexagonales et les
productions outre-mer il y a une grande
diversité de production il y a beaucoup
d'excellence c'est un premier élément
c'est la reconnaissance du travail des
agriculteurs et de leur capacité à
produire des produits de qualité le
deuxième message c'est la volonté qu'on
a ça a été évoqué sur plusieurs stands
je reviendrai d'ailleurs dans la semaine
ici c'est la volonté de de permettre à
ces territoires parfois très excentrés
parfois avec leur groupe évidemment leur
problème spécifique de faire en sorte
d'avoir accès à la souveraineté
alimentaire
l'entretien du jour avec Cyril Melchior
président du conseil départemental
au village réunion pour notre île
l'occasion pour nous de montrer le
savoir-faire des Réunionnais en matière
agricole agriculture c'est l'âme rénoès
c'est le temps anticipée et donc c'est
ce que on a voulu lui transmettre
aujourd'hui ce village il est inauguré
aujourd'hui avec 800 mètres carrés
d'espace des exposants encore plus
nombreux le département 1er moyen
pourquoi
tout simplement parce que chaque année
on se rend compte bien évidemment que
l'agriculture et ne laisse progresse il
faut accompagner justement tous ces
progrès la meilleure des vitrines c'est
quand même le Salon International de
Paris et donc lorsque nous offrons 800
mètres carrés d'espace à divers
exposants et je tiens à saluer les
remercier et bien c'est le savoir-faire
réunionnais que nous montrons à toute la
France mais aussi à l'international le
but pour nous c'est de montrer ce qu'on
sait faire de mieux en matière d'école
mais c'est aussi de dire aux Français et
à toutes les personnes qui passent ici
venez voir la réunion nous avons les
meilleurs produits du monde il y a un
contexte à ce salon des difficultés pour
les producteurs et agriculteurs le coût
des intrants notamment il y a aussi
l'inflation la lune contre la déchire
qui reste un sujet à la Réunion que
peuvent espérer les agriculteurs et
producteurs de la réunion de ce salon et
bien c'est de sensibiliser
tout un chacun d'abord les consommateurs
sur la variété la qualité la diversité
des produits rayonnés poissons nous
avons un label 100% Réunion c'est aussi
l'occasion d'attirer les pouvoirs
publics sur les difficultés
d'agriculture réunionnaise en termes de
réchauffement climatique de dérèglement
climatique il y a de vraies difficultés
notamment des sécheresses vous avez
aussi des épisodes iconiques qui sont de
plus en plus intenses donc c'est
l'occasion d'attirer l'attention des
pouvoirs publics sur les difficultés à
produire à la Réunion il éloignait avec
une géographie mais topographique des
sols en compte et puis bien évidemment
une exposition changement climatique qui
met en péril la culture et lyonnaise le
positionnement du conseil départemental
et stratégie pour la production agricole
réunionnaise est-ce que l'enjeu c'est
avant l'exportation vraiment de soutenir
et développer la production
nous voulons aller vers plus de
souveraineté alimentaire cela veut dire
quoi à chaque fois qu'on peut le faire
il faut produire pays par exemple pour
les œufs nous en sommes à 100% et bien
on peut aller aussi et à son poisson
pour un certain nombre de choses
notamment des fruits et légumes aux
joueurs de manière 70% on a encore des
branches de progression et donc le but
Quadro comme je vous l'ai dit c'est
d'aller vers plus de souveraineté
alimentaire parce que nous savons ce que
nous consommons il y a de la visibilité
il y a de la traçabilité il y a de la
qualité et c'est aussi pour participer à
l'effort de dire développement des
circuits courts bon produit à la Réunion
en consommant la Réunion et ça l'époque
le fait du jour l'inauguration de
village réunion en soutien la production
locale de nombreuses personnalités ont
fait le déplacement ravi le temps d'un
salon de faire tomber les 9000 km qui
les sépare de notre département
retrouvez le salon de l'agriculture
s'est retrouvé tous les prestataires
locaux que j'ai eu l'occasion de côtoyer
j'ai un disque quand j'étais Miss
Réunion sur le territoire de La Réunion
également lors de différents événements
où j'ai eu l'occasion de les accompagner
en tant que réunion et retrouver tous
ces acteurs locaux l'ambiance créole la
musique créole tous ces sourires
réunionnais qui montent ben voilà ça va
motiver à revenir les retrouver et puis
partager un bon moment ensemble voilà
une grande fierté en tant réunionnais
bien évidemment que nous les marmailles
ne mangent les produits pages et on est
fier aujourd'hui de pouvoir les défendre
en méditer de pouvoir encourager les
travaux sur cybersification et ça
demande énormément de courage de se
remettre en question
le mag au coeur du Salon international
de l'agriculture c'est fini pour
aujourd'hui on se retrouve dès demain